okay so Roy Moore the serial accused
child sex assault or who narrowly lost
the Alabama Senate election in 2017 to
Doug Jones after numerous sexual assault
allegations against him is running again
in 2020 and quite frankly why wouldn't
he I mean he almost won right I've told
you that despite being almost identical
on many issues
Republicans and Democrats handle sexual
assault allegations against candidates
in their party very very differently Roy
Moore got forty eight point three
percent of the vote in the election that
he ultimately lost in Alabama he almost
won so why wouldn't he run again you'll
remember compare and contrast that Al
Franken Democratic Senator for something
much more minor was forced to resign by
both Republicans but ultimately because
even Democrats said yeah Al Franken
should probably go while Roy Moore was
almost given a Senate seat despite
multiple allegations against him
including some involving teenage girls
and the funniest thing about this if
there's anything funny and this is
basically just serious but there's one
funny element about this there are
prominent Republicans pretending that
Roy Moore is an outlier in a sense that
he's not representative of the
Republican Party but they're actually
wrong unfortunately for the Republican
Party and for America this is exactly
representative of the Republican Party
nikki Haley is Donald Trump's former
ambassador to the United Nations she's
the former governor of South Carolina
and she came forward to say on Twitter
quote who in the world are his advisers
at what point does he think another run
will have a different response he does
not represent our Republican Party the
hell is she talking about this guy is
completely representative of the
Republican Party and you know that
because almost every Republican in
Alabama voted for him despite multiple
sexual assault allegations against
against him and he barely lost he got
forty eight point three percent of the
vote if Republicans had a problem with
Roy Moore if they felt that a candidate
riddled with sexual assault allegations
against him including those involving
teenage girls they wouldn't have all
elected him u.s. senator from Alabama
Trump was elected despite allegations
that he sexually assaulted countless
women including an underage girl
Alabama Republicans nominated Roy Moore
they selected him from a choice of
Republican options and then almost all
of them voted for him to a degree that
almost got him the Senate seat forty
eight point three percent of the total
vote so let's be clear yes there are
lots of Republicans like nikki Haley who
see Roy Moore's a second cand another
candidacy I don't know what number it
makes as a strategic mistake they say
well if someone else ran against
Democrat Doug Jones in the very red
state of Alabama we would likely win
this seat back from from Democrats but
with Roy Moore Doug Jones might get
himself reelected that's true but that's
simply the Republican Party seeing this
a sport which they do and seeing this as
wins and losses we'll see what happens
in the Republican primary in Alabama
there's still lots of time for other
Republicans to get in and challenge Roy
Moore very long list of possible
candidates already surfacing either way
regardless of this seat I don't see the
math for Democrats to take control of
the Senate in 2020 just because of which
seats are up for re-election but Doug
Jones holding on to the seat would be
terrific because it's one seat we don't
have to win back in 2022 in order to
take control of the Senate then again I
don't see any path for Democrats to take
control in 2020 but still holding the
Doug Jones seat rather than losing it
back to a Republican which is arguably
predictable in Alabama is one seat we
don't have to make up for in 2022
potentially to take control back of the
Senate so let's do what we can when the
time comes to help Doug Jones get
reelected in Alabama